big day today also for the bite
administration we're looking at a
hundred days in at how the
administration has done on a whole
variety of issues
and one of them uh is matters of race
and in fact i'm gonna walk over to the
monitor
where we've got some numbers here folks
you stay there we'll stay here i'm gonna
backwards walk over the monitor
so our cbs poll found that about 55
percent of americans
at this point 100 days in approve of how
president biden is handling race
relations in america
that's a poll that was taken after fired
police officer derrick shovin was found
guilty
in the killing of george floyd president
biden is now calling on the senate to
pass the george floyd justice and
policing act a reminder that would ban
choke holds
would also make it easier to prosecute
officers and set up a national police
misconduct
registry here's the big picture more
than 290 people have been killed by
police
so far this year and black americans are
killed by police at more than twice the
rate
of white americans that's why it's in
the news every day president biden also
says he is opposed to quote defunding
the police
and he has paused plans to establish a
police oversight commission
his administration is also using its
more than two trillion dollar
infrastructure plan to address economic
disparities i'm back now guys economic
disparities between black and white
americans
uh including uh money to do things like
replace
lead pipes in flint michigan that was a
big story i remember being out there
and also mississippi also had a water
crisis there we didn't talk about quite
as much
um so this was one of the four major
crises he said he inherited when he
entered office and
that's an overlook at what he's done to
address it 100 days in
that alone is a full-time job because it
appears to need to be getting worse
doesn't appear to be getting better
there is that feeling yeah
there is that feeling it will be
interesting to hear to see what he has
to say tonight
all right we're joined now by mark
morial the national urban league
president and ceo
and former mayor of new orleans we
should know mark is married to cbs this
morning saturday co-host michelle miller
that's a good thing because we love
michelle so mark good morning thanks for
joining us
uh mark you heard the number that tony
just said 55 percent of americans in our
poll
say they approve of presidents biden's
handling of race relations
how do you think he's doing
first of all thank you for having me
good morning anthony the
president has been purposeful and
intentional
about including racial justice
components in
every policy he's undertaken in the
first 100 years
in covit he's expanded community-based
vaccination sites in the cabinet
with vice president harris and all the
way through he's had the most
diverse cabinet in modern american
history in the american rescue plan
there are anti-poverty provisions and
provisions to assist
businesses owned by people of color
including african americans
and his commitment to racial justice his
forward-leaning
support for the george floyd justice and
policing act the minimum wage
along with the idea that infrastructure
and this is a recommendation we made to
him both as a candidate
and in the transition has to include
investments in human beings
so this president's start is purposeful
it's intentional and
the support amongst the public i think
demonstrates
that the president has used his moral
voice to create a distinction between
the poisonous philosophy of white
supremacy and the idea of
an america for everyone in america with
opportunity
and pathways to progress for all people
mark
the president said he would prioritize
racial justice and you said
you'd hold him to that what more would
you like to see
well first of all we need uh kristen
clarke to be confirmed as the chief
civil
rights enforcer as assistant attorney
general for civil rights
number two we need passage of the
justice and policing act
the george floyd justice and policing
act we need a
minimum wage increase which is long
overdue we haven't had a national
increase
since 2007 and we need an
assault on this pandemic of voter
suppression now with 250 bills
being introduced all across the nation
the weight of the presidency
we need the weight of the justice
department uh and we also need
cooperation uh from uh from what i would
call some
the members of the united states senate
who seem to be held bent on blocking
progress the president's numbers
demonstrate
uh and his electoral victory
demonstrates that he has i think a broad
base of support amongst the american
people it's not universal
but it's broad and i think it's deep
because people want accomplishments
they want progress and i think on race
relations uh president biden
i believe has gotten off to a powerful
and a purposeful start but there is a
lot left to be done anthony this
hundred day if you will mark is sort of
an artificial deadline
but since uh it's uh it's part of our
sort of tradition going back
to president franklin roosevelt it's
important it's an important time to talk
about
uh where the president is and where the
nation is and i'll say this
the other important thing is the
president has changed the tone
of governing to an inclusive tone of
governing away from
a reality show finger-pointing uh
disparagement tone that existed for the
last four years
and i think that creates pathways for
him to achieve real progress we will
continue to hold him accountable
but so far the start is purposeful well
as you know mark the justice department
is now investigating not one but two
police departments some say that's a
sign that they're taking it seriously
president biden is urging congress to
pass legislation
oh there he is there you are mark we
lost you for just a second
so you know it's a very tense time
between the
communities of color and the police
department police departments all over
the country
what do you think needs to be done how
can we effectively address that issue
and what should team biden be doing
about that at this particular time
so i think that mayor garland and the
department of justice have taken two
important steps
just in the last week and that that is
to engage in pattern and
practice uh investigations both in
minneapolis
as well as as in louisville that means
that the president
and his justice department are going to
use the full weight and the full
toolbox available to them on the issue
of
policing and improving trust but yep
these killings are gut-wrenching they're
hurtful i have a 19 year old son
when i see these young men i shudder i i
feel a sense of great pain like all of
us do
but this is what's important the
president the justice department
the national government cannot fix the
problem of policing alone
it takes every community every mayor
city council
county exec states like maryland have
put a marker down with the statewide law
everyone has to be in this because this
system is broken
this system uh uh for the most part uh
has lost
great faith amongst the american people
and we need to restore it
but we need a new vision on how we keep
communities safe
yeah well you can't fix it if you don't
acknowledge it it at least appears that
the biden administration is
acknowledging houston we have a big
problem mark marielle it's always good
to see you
our best in the show yes sir you're
gonna see her before we do he's the best
yeah we think she's the best thanks a
lot we will bring you a special report
on the president's address to congress
that starts tonight at nine o'clock
eastern
right here on cbs